so you've come out to la armed with
scripts and
are you also auditioning too yes and you
know you have this
other talent which is to draw um how
soon before you say
well i'm going to try to utilize that
to make a living and and fulfill my
artistic
well here's the thing
i always believe that when an
opportunity arises
take it um and what happened was i i
mentioned earlier that that my wife
leanne was was in casting
and um she had gotten a job
at walt disney feature animation in the
casting department i think they were
i think they were working on hunchback
um at the time
and um and she had been there for a few
months and and
she was really liking working there and
just by being there she met the
people in the animation department and
the producers of the animated shows and
so forth and she got to see
basically how things work there and she
she i remember her calling me up
from work one day and saying you know
you could do
this like you could definitely do this
and i was like well i guess but you know
i'm
not i don't know anything about
animation i didn't
except for animating little clay figures
you know for super 8 movies um
but she she said well you should you
should you know find out
because you could get a job here like
they're looking for people because
you know jeffrey katzenberg had
was just opening up dreamwork down the
street
and was grabbing up lots of animators
you know and poaching them from disney
to you know to stock up you know his
his studio so everybody was looking for
animators so i was like okay well
i'll i'll go and take a class i guess
i went to the animation union
and so i started taking classes there in
a hurry
i was taking as many as i could right
and
even though because because even though
i was act i was
working i was a working screenwriter you
know
a working screenwriter can not work for
a year sometimes
right and so it was
feast or famine most of the time and i'm
i was still i was
when i sold a script it was really good
money but then it might be
a long time before i sold another one i
mean at least
at least one that got made um you know
you get paid
something for for writing it but you get
a lot of money if the movie gets made
for that we call the first day of
principal check which is
really nice um so
i thought well wouldn't it be nice
though to because
now i'd been writing for you know a few
years wouldn't it be nice to have like
an actual
steady job steady paycheck for a while
so so i went and i learned i learned
about animation really fast
right took all these classes these uh i
learned
how to uh what kind of a portfolio to
submit
um because uh that's that's that's where
a lot of people go wrong
uh when when trying to get a job back
then at least trying to get a job in
animation is that
they would turn in a portfolio filled
with drawings of mickey mouse and goofy
and that was the last thing that disney
animation wanted to see
they wanted to see that you could draw
that you could draw
human figures that you could do life
drawing gesture drawing
you know real artwork not just traced
cartoons
right so so i did i put together a
portfolio and i submitted it and i
and i got in so that was good
it was in fact it was great i started
working on hercules like almost
immediately
uh that was the good side the bad side
was i had to tell
my manager that i could not
do any i couldn't take any riding gigs
because once you're under the umbrella
of a corporation like that
the walt disney company is a very big
umbrella
they have you know they have music
departments and they have you know
obviously they make movies also and so
if you are a full-time employee um and
this is not just disney by the way this
is
all studios if you're under their
employee
you cannot work for a
you know competition so if you write a
script
while you are working for them
technically they own it and the kind of
hoops that you have to go through to
get it cleared so that you could take it
somewhere else
is just it would take months right
so i couldn't i couldn't i couldn't be a
writer for hire
for anywhere anywhere else um they
didn't look
disney didn't look at me as a writer
they looked at me as an artist
but it didn't matter same thing you know
other artists i was working for who
created their own music
disney owned it as long as it was
written
and and put out you know while working
for them
um and it's a way to protect themselves
i get it that's i
that it didn't bother me but i think my
my manager at the time was not
very happy about it because because i
was i was
i was working i was bringing in you know
bringing in
she was getting me jobs so um so
that was the downside of it for sure but
i i loved it i i like
working on hercules it was the first one
and they were already
well into the production of hercules by
the time that i
got in there by the way also i i think i
was in my mid-30s
at the time right all the other people
who came in with me
in that group that of trainees
they were all fresh out of uh cal arts
so they were all like you know 21 you
know whatever
i was like the old man of the group so
it was like it just it seemed kind of
weird but
i didn't care i was i was just so happy
to be working there and to
be working on that level
of entertainment you know a
big movie that's gonna everybody's gonna
see it
and um even you know even though i'm a
small part of a much bigger
team you know i'd still be part of it i
could still look at scenes and go ah i
did that scene that's cool
yeah and so um so i stayed
until the job became obsolete basically
how did it become obsolete because uh
because of pixar because the pixar
movies were
making a lot of money and the hand-drawn
movies
at disney were not living living up to
expectation
i think that the um the powers that be
kind of look equated
cg movies make money hand-drawn movies
don't and
that's that wasn't true but from a
making point of view
i'm sure that's what they thought the
truth is
the the scripts weren't as good as the
ones that pixar was putting
out and it always starts with the script
i mean
you could have made finding nemo
hand-drawn and it would still be just as
good
it would be the same movie it would just
look a little different
i would still be a fantastic movie you
know the lion king
would still be you know a terrific movie
if it was done hand-drawn oh
wait lion king was to a hand-drawn um i
i was up
there saying like well the lion king
would be just as good if you did it in
cg
i know it's making a lot of money i
haven't seen it yet though but you know
the point is
that sure it was it was it was just that
this the scripts weren't
catching the eye of the public
um it was either the wrong demographic
that they were looking at because they
were doing they were experimenting a
little bit
like movies like atlantis uh and
treasure planet
which were not you know disney princess
movies um
so and i i admired the fact that they
were trying to branch out and see
but it those movies just did not
um live up to their potential and sorry
what year was this when they kind of
made this shift
when they decided well i started on
hercules
in 1996
so i had been screenwriting for
three or four years um before that
right but when disney decided to go away
from the countdown
so that happened
early 2000s um i think that the last
the last movie i worked on was called
home on the range
and i think that that came out in 2003
i want to say somewhere around there so
it was it was
the early part of the 2000s that
somewhere or right around there they
made the decision that
that home on the range would be the last
um hand-drawn
film how much talk before had had it
been years of build up to that point
did you hear that in the air yes but not
a lot of years
i can really i mean i some of us could
see the writing on the wall
and others refuse to believe it um
i can remember saying to somebody
at one point maybe it was while we were
making tarzan and they were starting to
use they were really starting to utilize
um
cg elements into the 2d movies and and
of course
the pixar movies were already doing
great you know bugs life and so forth
were doing really well
um and i remember saying to one of my
colleagues there
i said you know i think 10 years from
now
they're all going to be cg and the
person i was talking to and i don't
remember who it was but it was just like
no way
that's there's no way that's not
possible and
it turns out i was wrong it it only took
five years wow so it happened pretty
pretty quickly so i mean even by the
last movie by home on the range by that
time
you know we had all been told this was
the last one
um and it was that was not a good time i
mean
that last that last year um was was
morale was very low and um uh
you know it's kind of some of those
people
like i said you know these kids had come
straight out of cal arts right well they
you know they had just done that
recently but there were people who were
working at that company
for 40 years who never had
another kind of job yeah you know they
never even worked
fast food or whatever they came right
out of calarts you know because cal
arts was created to basically groom
disney artists
they they went right to work and they
were there their whole their whole
existence and and now all of a sudden
they're
you know they're in their 50s and and
their job is gone
and it's not like you could even go to
another studio all the studios were
doing it
um so that was a you know it was a big
transition for a lot of people now
um i don't i don't blame disney at all i
mean i think it's
it's evolution um in a way i mean this
is this is
what happens um with all kinds of art i
think
um but uh
i felt bad for a lot of people who did
not
you know know what to do you know people
buy
expensive houses and expensive cars and
everything like that when things are
going great and uh
that's why when occasionally um i i'll
go back to my college
um in new york to uh to just
be a guest speaker and things like that
and talk to people about
animation or acting or filmmaking and
general screenwriting
and one of the things i always tell them
is um
uh you know pursue your dreams for sure
but have a backup plan because you never
know when
the the rug can be pulled out from under
you like we never
imagined that i thought i was going to
work for disney forever
you know and then all of a sudden
it ended um and and i could have i could
have tried to learn
cg and disney was great in that regard
because
they actually offered us free classes to
to learn it and i took advantage of that
i
i took the classes and learned the maya
cg program but i couldn't
i couldn't find the joy in it it's a big
difference nowadays it's a
it's easier because now they have wacom
tablets where you can
you can draw right on the screen so it's
your drawing again but back
then the difference between drawing the
tactile difference between drawing with
a pencil
and moving a mouse and clicking a mouse
very very different things
and that wasn't for me
what did some of those people end up
doing i mean their whole identity was
disrupted this was who they were
yeah and a lot of people it's how they
define themselves
so suddenly you have to find something
new to do
i mean i you know look i saw people that
i knew that were pulling down
you know nice nice fat paychecks every
week at disney
who were then working at trader joe's
and there's nothing wrong with working
at trader joe's but
my point is that it was the
the difference in the the amount of
money that you're bringing in
is substantial and it's because
that's all they knew and there's if
there wasn't any animation work anymore
what are you going to do you got to find
some other way to make money and
i people did all kinds of things some
people moved away and i don't know what
they did and
some people started working on
doing storyboards for live action movies
and
um some of my friends who came in with
me in that training class um
uh ended up directing tv shows for
disney
and uh and writing for tv shows for
disney and so forth
so some of us found our way
right so the so they offered you these
free classes
you used the program called maya you
said yeah
okay back then that was that was the
main program that they used for cg back
then
and you just knew pretty much instantly
this is not going to be for me
not instantly it took it took a couple
of months
before i was just like
my brain isn't wired for that
um i might you know
that there's that
that tactile thing where you're holding
a pencil between your fingers
and you know these it's running up here
and then running back down again
and i got nothing from moving that
mouse around there was nothing that
wasn't happening
and and i was just like well maybe um
maybe i can go back to screenwriting
um and you know there were every once in
a while there would be
a special project that came up that
needed 2d
my wife helped produce um a series of um
uh educational films that had timon and
pumbaa from the lion king
and they did those in 2d and i got to
work on those and
and every once in a while something pops
up i mean just last year um i got hired
to work on mary poppins returns
and got to uh you know work on animating
the the penguins
that you know dance with lin-manuel
miranda and
[Music]
emily blind and that was really cool
that was really cool um because that
scene in the original movie with dick
van dyke was my favorite scene in the
whole movie so
um so stuff don't does come up but it's
obviously it's
cg is is really
is the leading technology for doing
animation now
there's talk i hear rumors they disney
might go back to doing some 2d movies
they did do princess and the bro
and the frog a few years after home on
the range
which i didn't work on the movie itself
i did work on
some of the sort of commercials for it
um
but uh but um i've heard
i hear these rumblings and you never
know if there are rumors if they're true
or not but they said that there
there might be some consideration of
returning to
to 2d for for certain projects
and then you gave your two weeks notice
or it wasn't a two weeks notice you were
you were given two weeks
they gave me they gave me like a
two-month notice
okay it was like a severance or
something and you then you got a call
so you knew this date was coming that
you would be out of a job yeah
and then they did it in waves as as we
got further along on home on the range
they they would let a certain amount of
people go
and then you know a few months later a
certain amount of people go and so forth
i i managed to
hang on right to the very end and this
is in 2006
no earlier earlier okay i think it was i
think it was
2000 i think it was 2003 actually okay
so the economy is doing decent so it's
not like they're letting you go in 2009
right you're and then as luck would have
it your phone rings yes
yeah right around that time i mean it
was like within a week
uh i out of the blue i get a call from
todd trina
um who i had worked with uh on a great
script
many years before um called woodstuck
that still hasn't never been made but it
was it was again
a script that helped me get other work
um
and i really liked todd when we were
working on that back then really
we did we definitely got along really
well and everything like that and
and it just so happened that right
around the time the disney gig was
ending
todd called me up and and said hey are
you available i have an idea for a
script i'd love you to work
on with me and uh i was like oh as a
matter of fact
your timing is perfect and so uh so i
i started working with todd on the
script uh
that we called um without a hitch at
that
at that time which was todd todd's a
great idea guy he would come up with a
great concept
for a movie and then um we would we
would
bash out ideas you know over drinks
often and uh and then
and then basically he would send me off
to to to write a first draft
and uh and then i'd bring it back to him
and we'd talk it all over and we'd come
up with new ideas and
and you know then work on a second draft
and so forth and so forth
as long as many drafts as it needs to um
before it's ready to
to to put out there
and todd has his own production company
or he's been a producer and
forgive me how did you two meet again um
basically
todd was um was helping bankroll a a
small
in very small independent
group of one filmmaker basically
um and this was the guy who had hired me
to write this script that was called
woodstock
and so so i met todd through the
director
of um who the guy who was going to be
the director of woodstock and
um like i said we just i i liked him
immediately
so you stayed in touch he's in the san
francisco bay area he would know he was
still
at that time he's up there now his
family is all up there but uh
he was he was actually living living
down here um
and uh you know we'd meet up
occasionally and
you know go out and have a dinner or
something like that but but then we
started really working together
uh on on this script that he had this
idea for
and uh it's a uh it was a
a long time uh uh we'd work on it for a
few months and and then
you know other things would happen and
then a year later we'd come back and
work on it again
and some fresh idea would show up or
something like that so
um and uh we just have a very good
working relationship
yeah and so you've known each other like
a good amount of time 10 past years yeah
since since the early 90s
and so the one idea that he called you
about has now turned into the movie
that's already out which is
i hate kids i hate kids without a hitch
we had done all kinds of drafts on on
on without a hitch um and uh
you know adding characters changing
characters changing endings changing
beginnings
you know everything um to to get it
what we felt was right
um and uh
we were i think we were
we were right on the verge like we knew
we were getting really close
and i said well maybe we need a fresh
title to sort of you know just spark
hit that spark plug again right and
um originally the the lead character in
in in with
without a hitch was uh the nick
was um he was a uh was a guy who owned a
big
surfing um company like surfing clothes
and clothes and so forth right
and somehow it just i don't know it
wasn't
really gelling and i
said what if he was because he because
the character wasn't wasn't
didn't have a lot of humor to him and i
thought well
what if we gave him an occupation where
humor was part of his job and he said
what if he's a
what if he's a writer what if he's a guy
who writes funny books
i know observational humor kind of thing
and that really that that fire took off
without a doubt and uh i think we i
think we made him british for a while
too
we were like um um uh who are we basing
it on
hugh iq oh hugh grant you know
because because i remember that uh todd
loves about a boy that movie about a boy
so um
but but but the writing having the
character be a writer being a
being a a humorist definitely helped
us gel that character and uh
and so i thought well he doesn't we know
he doesn't like
children and and his he's marrying
someone who doesn't like children so why
wouldn't his book be called i8 kids
and that immediately became the title of
the movie
so which we changed it from without a
hitch to i hate kids
and we knew the title was working
because
every time we said it to somebody they
laughed
every single time we said well what's
the name of the movie it's called i hate
kids and they would laugh
because everybody can appreciate that
one way or another you know what i mean
and uh uh and then
um we started showing it around
or todd did i i wasn't involved that
part of it todd's the
the business end of things you know and
um and he showed it to the
the right people at one point who wanted
to
were interested in in making it how does
that work
when when someone has this idea did he
already write a rough draft of it
and then you started working on it i if
i remember correctly and i'd have to
check with todd if this is right um
i think that at the very beginning i
think that there was
at least it was either an outline or it
was
uh it was a written opening scene
which was a wedding so it was an actual
wedding
um where this this kid shows up and and
says that you know i'm your i'm your dad
i mean you're my dad
um and that throws the whole thing into
chaos
um and but it wasn't
it wasn't more than just i think a scene
so we really had to then
really develop where it was going to go
um um we we picked we i mean todd
already imagined it was going to be a
kind of a road trip movie oh okay
so i mean the idea of it being that this
guy is about to get married to
a woman and they both the thing that
they share is neither of them are
interested in having children
so um at the uh originally it was the
wedding itself
in the in the final draft of the script
the shooting script we
had it um the wedding rehearsal because
that would put a
ticking bomb uh on into the script
automatically so he's got to figure he's
got to get this problem figured out
before the wedding which is in three
days
so um uh so this kid shows up says
you know you're my dad and uh he doesn't
believe him
of course uh at first but um this
he's the kid has brought along with him
this psychic
the amazing fabular who has determined
that nick is in fact this kid's
uh father and uh
yes nick still doesn't believe it of
course until um
we have this very funny scene that we
worked out where
how how does the kid know for sure that
that's his dad
and i'm pretty sure i came up with this
um
because he's a celebrity of some sort
right
his barber has been selling locks of his
hair
on ebay so the kid buys
a lock of his hair on ebay and then
sends it to a dna lab with his own hair
and the test comes back positive right
so
but but the psychic is still claiming
you know
that it was all his his doing right so
the three of them then go on a road trip
to try to find the kid's mom
he doesn't know who his mom is uh
and at the time the kid is now 14
13 or 14 and at the time that nick
that the kid was conceived nick was
dating a lot of women
so the idea is now he's got to figure
out which of these many women
is the mother of this kid and that so
that's what propels everything forward
um and i remember that we came up with
the the psychic
very late in the game really and over
the course of
you know however many years it was 12
years or something like that but
um because we we
just thought it would be funny to have a
psychic with a little tiny dog
that's going along with it because it
also it also made a triangle
for the three main characters to play
off of each other it wouldn't just be
the father and the son you've also got
this irritating
you know kind of flamboyant uh
uh psychic there to constantly be
you know insulting nick and and
being nice to the kid and the kid being
nice to both of them and
it set up this really cool dynamic
between the three of them
you